[Music]
welcome to to monkey
we gotta go get on my back I would
rather die get on my back nope I'm going
down
I like can't even with this place
well the fun group welcome to detention
Spencer
definite fridge Martha you're all here
for a reason you should be thinking
about who you are and who you want to be
you'll have plenty of time to figure
that out while you're cleaning of the
basement are you gonna help
are you too pretty I'm too pretty yo
what's this a game for those who seek to
find a way to leave their world behind
Jumanji pick a character and you're that
person in the game
what's one real quick I don't think it
matters how much you spin ball sounds
like a badass I'll be the curvy genius
dr. smolder brave still guessin ruby
roundhouse
guys hey where's the rest of me my god
fridge damn fridge who you me Spencer
why I'm wearing half a shirt and short
shorts in the jungle think we got sucked
into Jumanji we've become the avatars we
chose so that means Bethany Bethany
don't look at it I'm an overweight
middle-aged man I don't have my claritin
and all I see around here is pop but I
don't have a top the fate of my body
damn it as a man right there don't cry
don't cry don't cry it's gonna be okay
this is a video game which means we all
have special skills
it was so intense I like can't even with
this place
[Music]
we were all in a coma what no no game
machine muscle like you get in there
saver
I don't not gonna get in there you get
in there yeah I got a backpack oh you
don't get a water with a backpack
everybody knows that
[Music]